hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you can join me for this video where
I'll be discussing you know one of my
favorite trading setups trading
strategies you know strategies is a
misused term when people you know for me
when I talk about strategies people
think it's like some fully automated
strategy basically a strategy for me is
um you know identifying a trade setup
and taking the trade now you know if you
haven't already be sure you hit
subscribe to my channel so you'll be
notified of you know any new videos that
come out now
I'm going to be talking about is you
know it's a trading strategy setup that
I like to see around highs and lows of
the day now it doesn't happen every
single day and it doesn't happen in
every Market it is volume related so you
know you're going to need an order flow
footprint chart so you know just really
quick you know before we jump in a dome
right people say well dome's really the
order flow well it's it's not it's just
orders going into the market it's not
actually trading what I'm focusing in on
is
um volumes that actually trade so you
can see right this is the Dome the depth
of Market on gold because it occurred
today in gold and it occurred today also
in um the ultra bonds right and you can
see our Ultra bonds trade
um you know several hundred contracts at
each level right it's a pretty liquid
contract gold is a lot less liquid right
you're seeing you know anywhere between
10 and 20 contracts on the offers
and what I like to look for
okay is precisely this let's go back
here to the high of the day in Gold okay
now again this is I'm
looking at the highs and lows of days
right I'm always interested when the
market makes a high how it makes it
made a high traded one contract it's a
green candle okay but if I'm looking you
know if I'm looking to get short off a
high I don't like to get short off of uh
green bars because you know sort of the
underlying pressure in the market so to
speak is still bullish right because we
are closing you know above where we open
we just sort of pulled back off that
high but if I get a red candle at the
high right or we're closing go up here
make a new high and close lower right
it's got my interest right because I
know that price action in the bar is
still
um is bearish okay
and what I'm looking at is this green
line here is the high of the day by the
way again if you're using ninja Trader
there's actually an indicator on here
it's called current oh day OHL open high
low close you just scroll down in there
you can see it uh right in here you just
add it and again you can change whatever
I just use the default colors
um green for the current high red for
the current low
and I'm walking at the volume between
one contract okay now
you know you use it in the order flow
it's easy to see sometimes you might
miss it but
in the order flows Trader we have what
we call the exhaustion prints right
right here
let's set it to one to highlight those
bars
that just have
um one in there
okay so let's do that and wait for
seconds okay so you can see here now
it's drawing out this red line so I know
there's a there's a single contract that
traded there because remember right in
the dome right there's decent volume on
both sides in this case this is gold
okay people say well gold doesn't trade
that much and you can see the volumes
are light you know this is a one minute
chart and again today was a jack not a
fed day but Powell was speaking at
Jackson Hole so you got very good
volumes going through this bar
here all right let's get this Dome out
of the way this bar here traded 1400
contracts
and it traded one contract right so
that's going to be different than say
um
you know if if you're looking at you
know maybe a different contract like
that doesn't trade as much volume right
where you're going to get you know you
know in a one minute bar you're gonna
trade you know a lot less volume but
when I see that to me that's a sign this
Market doesn't want to go any higher it
makes a new high by what is that two
ticks
one contract where is the fresh buying
coming in it's not there right for this
market to continue going higher you want
to see more and more buying not just one
contract at the high and again people
say well what about this one it's also
one contract you know the market did
come off but I I like it to be you know
also have some price action in the bar
to signal to me that you know what yeah
there was
um some nice
selling pressure in the bar and the bar
closed lower
now
like I said you know when you're looking
at order flow again it depends on the
market that you're trading right if I
was looking at you know a different
Market Hogs
and don't laugh I mean there are traders
that trade Hogs I mean I think it's a
fantastic Market to trade I think every
Futures Market is fantastic to trade but
at the same time right
just going back here where's our high up
here you know you also got one we only
got 100 contracts trade on this at this
High here okay here you got it if I was
looking at
um here it's almost uh this is a one
down here it's a little hard to see but
again it's a doji candle candle open and
closed at the same price if this was a
green bar this is probably one I'd be
looking to to take but you know the bar
closed I like to get long off green
candles at the low as opposed to doji
candles
um or red candles at the low right and
again you know all those price action
guys oh you got that uh pin bar here
right you got the the doji candle the
very long Wick it's got to be bullish
well in this case it wasn't right I mean
people always like to post pictures of
candles like this in the market rallies
but they never post a picture like this
um you know you get down here near the
lows I mean it was a 2 a 17. I'm just
looking for a simple thing one right
it's it's not
not that hard
um Ultra bonds okay let's take a look at
Ultra bonds now Ultra bonds you know
trades very good con uh volume right you
can see here volumes you know 200 200
400 uh 282 300 400 300 Etc okay
um now Ultra bonds right any interest
rates I like looking at a four range
chart okay I just find it easier to
trade than looking at a one minute chart
right if you're looking at a one minute
chart
um because yeah it's a contract that
trades a lot of volume it doesn't move
around a lot right so here this is a one
minute chart and you can see in here
right
27 contracts 24 3. basically it's
trading either the bid or the offer and
sometimes it takes one tick above one
tick below right I just find I've always
traded
um interest rates on a um on a range
based chart and down here today
look at this making new lows making new
lows making my way
um
Divergence Divergence and down here one
contract this bar traded 1200 contracts
it only traded a one down here right we
had strong selling right making new lows
new lows then only one person interested
in selling down here
what is what do you think that means
well if you got one person interested in
selling probably not gonna go any lower
all right then you can start then you
start adding in the other pieces of
order flow right when I talk about
strategy right then that's sort of your
your
what do you want to call it your key
part of the order flow is looking for
that exhaustion in the market the last
seller has sold then you start looking
okay what else is happening well I got
aggressive buying coming in
okay and you know what else do you see
well I see a
single print in this bar
right a five right I see a bullish
Prominent Point of control there's
actually a bullish primary point of
control down here as well I also I got a
bullish ratio as well 450. I don't have
a Divergence because this bar has a
negative Delta
okay so that single print to me is the
go sign that hey you know what
pay attention we can start rallying off
this low as opposed to we didn't rally
off this Divergence or this Divergence
or this Divergence
right which normally you know people
would be looking for you have a
Divergence
um you'd be looking for the market to
start to rally and it didn't
until it got down here where the last
seller had sold Why didn't it rally
anymore it's probably because you still
got selling pressure taking place in the
market
now you know on other markets right like
say the the e-minis right a much more
deeper liquid Market you don't get a lot
of
ones at the highs or lows so if you did
see it in the e-minis
um you gotta jump all over it right up
here at the high I think the volume was
just uh
I think it was just 25.
okay
um here but that's a green up candle
look at something I like to look for at
the highs or the lows of the day you
know 79 152 right s PS is just one of
those markets that does a very good job
of Distributing volume throughout the
bar right you don't get a lot of those
um
one
one contract prints at highs or lows of
the day right nothing in here
all right 12.
not even down here
okay so again it's not something that
you necessarily use on e-minis I think
it'd be a very
um
strong signal if you saw it on the
e-minis but I can't remember the last
time I saw high or low in the e-minis
High a day low of the day where it
traded just one contract I see it a lot
in other contracts
um
you know as well so
take a look again not everybody trades
um you know e-mini so if you're trading
something like interest rates pay
attention to that Ultra bonds
um you know obviously gold that happens
in crude time to time but again it's not
something that you're going to see every
day because at the end of the day it is
volume dependent right it's it's based
on the conditions in the market so that
wraps up this volume this volume this
video on you know analyzing the volume
in the footprint and started talking
about one of my favorite trade setups
and to be honest this is something I
have always looked at in the order flow
for over a decade you know even before I
put my software together and those of
you that have been following me since I
released the software know that this is
something that I've looked at in the in
the past they've even wrote about it in
my book uh trading order flow okay so
you that that's how important this is to
me and this is so simple basic thing
right and you know if you're
it's really quick right
all right let's go back to the Ultra
Bond chart
right that's just on one contract right
a one there
um you know on these contracts you don't
have to necessarily use a one
right maybe you want to use five as your
level right if it's a market that you're
familiar with and you know that it's
rare to get you know a one maybe you
want to move it out to five
maybe even nine recipes I use nine
so again
um thanks guys for watching this video
and hopefully you got something useful
see you guys on the next video bye-bye